there's a pomposity to film sets yeah
get them into the works like what does
that mean oh hair and makeup uh yeah
they're traveling copy that copy that no
you're not in the military not the army
uh that ten one ten one is going to the
bathroom say i'm going to the bathroom i
gotta go to the bathroom there's no
shame in that we all do it hi i'm seth
macfarlane and these are my iconic
characters
[Music]
family guy
life of larry was a student film that i
had done at the rhode island school of
design and i conceived that to be a
pilot that would get me to hollywood
hanna-barbera saw that film and gave me
a job worked on a show called johnny
bravo worked on a show called dexter's
lab cow and chicken did a
a a pitch for a prime time animated
series called family guy
developed it while i was at
hanna-barbera cartoon network came to
the attention of fox pitched the show
they gave me like a forty thousand
dollar budget uh to do the pilot which
meant i pretty much had to do it by hand
so i spent six months doing that and
that eventually became became family guy
oh you got some pyre can i have a piece
uh sure ooh let me have some of that
cool whip what'd you say you can't have
a pie without cool whip cool whip cool
whip yeah you mean cool whip yeah cool
whip who are the griffins well i'm not
sure who they are now but
when i was there the family was always
designed to be a very region specific i
just graduated from college in
providence and so i was very familiar
familiar with that region it was in many
ways like a mini boston the dialect was
more or less the same it's a ridiculous
part of the country in a lot of ways the
dialect is and you know i have members
of my family who have it but it's
hilarious when employed in in the
interest of comedy these characters were
they all came from different places i
mean peter and brian were very much
vaudevillian opposites of each other
well peter you might be underestimating
the difficulty of writing a comic strip
as someone who occasionally dates the
creative muse i can vouch for the
unforgiving face of a blank sheet of
paper in fact i think it was william
faulkner who said i'm back i'm published
check it out lois began very much as an
avatar for my aunt she became something
very different uh mostly thanks to alex
borstein you know meg and chris are the
the quintessential animated kids stewie
was rex harrison the character actor
from the 1960s and 50s and 60s it was
henry higgins there there there who's
hurting you your silly girl what'd you
take me for i thought this was gonna be
a lawn party i don't have one pair of
long pants generally for me the voices
came first peter was a mixture of a lot
of different
you know voices there was a security
guard that worked at the rhode island
school of design who had
this really really thick really
expressive rhode island accent boy you
guys are not sucking me into the story
at all
i'm just telling you for your own
benefit
i'm very aware that i'm watching a play
right now quagmire started off as
throwback to this you know this
guy whose house looked like
you know something of a peter sellers
movie and that voice kind of came from
um
me listening to
old radio dramas from the 50s when there
was a bookstore in my hometown when i
was a kid and you could go in and they
sold audio tapes you know things like
the lone ranger or suspense or the
shadow and the commercials were so just
so absurd and just you know everybody
talked like this and it was just you
know that sort of mid-atlantic i guess
existed right in the pocket that the
microphones of that time could handle
the low end wasn't there yet and and so
it was all about all about mid-range oh
hey
uh
didn't think i'd see anyone i knew here
there's no daniel day-lewis process that
goes on here with these kids
it's not
it's not that deep there are certain
facial contortions that you know you do
stewie and this happens right through
peter and the chaperone so it's it's a
little it's a little bit of that i've
been doing all those characters for so
long
that it really is just a it's like
turning one light off and another one on
where did the inspiration to do
animation come from i mean all those
things were influences all the family
was an influence the twilight zone star
trek obviously what disney was doing at
the time was a huge influence when i was
in college
disney was kind of having its second
golden age with little mermaid beauty
the beast and aladdin in those movies
and everyone in our film department in
in the animation division kind of saw
that as the ultimate goals like to work
for disney would be the would be you
know and now heck technically i do so
that was kind of what i was what i was
really striving for i was doing stand-up
at the same time the simpsons started to
take off
and that that altered my trajectory
because i was really loving doing
stand-up but obviously that wasn't the
kind of comedy i'd be doing if i worked
for disney i started to kind of rethink
things i thought they've kind of
rewritten the rule book suddenly i'm
watching a cartoon that actually is
making me laugh it's for me as an adult
this changes the game these these you
know the kind of humor that makes me
laugh and the stuff that i was doing in
my stand-up routines could now maybe
meld with animation and so that that
show was instrumental in altering my my
trajectory and i'm sure the trajectories
of a lot of other people who are in the
business i mean you know from king of
the hill to bob's burgers to south park
you know all those shows
owe their existence i think and there's
they're in many ways their stylistic
paradigm to the simpsons the thing i
liked about animation was that it gave
me the chance to explore a lot of
different art forms
that interested me and had interest in
me throughout the course of my life all
in one
package animation is is and i don't know
any other medium can really say that
it's visual art it's performance art the
voice over
it's writing and it's music all of those
things exist in this one package there's
always a different art form to play with
in that medium that's what excited me
the most time to terrorize the
terrorists ugh you prepared catchphrases
for yourself no not necessarily to me
the catchphrases are the least
interesting things they kind of find you
as opposed to the reverse there was a
guy i worked with at hanna-barbera he
was a very business-minded uh writer and
he said you know never underestimate the
importance of a catchphrase it is
something that really makes a difference
it's not something that i set out to do
you like you you you do it people laugh
at the table read so you add it in next
week and then suddenly you have a
catchphrase honey your hands are filthy
go wash up for lunch eat my shorts
eat my shorts i love that is that a
popular expression like what the deuce
probably more popular probably probably
way more popular a stand-up comic friend
of mine named steve marmel i guess he
was a jerry lewis fan or something
you know he would he would say hey guys
i'd be like uh googie and you know so it
it devolved into this
this kind of lazy
um just distilling of of jerry lewis
nonsense that uh that then became
giggity giggity giggity they come from
weird places
ted
ted was conceived as actually as an
animated series that it was it was the
same idea was a guy who had had a teddy
bear would come to life when he was a
kid and now he still had to deal with it
the thing was still around but now as i
get a wife and kids and and there was a
whole family component i kind of went
out the window when we
had the thought of maybe doing this as a
film i thought at one point is this a
hand puppet thing is it like a greg the
bunny sort of situation i wrote the um
the initial story and then uh co-wrote
the the screenplay with alex sulkin and
and wellesley wilde i think we pitched
it to 20th century fox
they asked us can you do a pg-13 version
so we went we wrote a pg-13 version i
think at the end of the day they just
felt like this is just too expensive
it's too weird it's too risky there's
there's a cgi bear at the center of this
it's going to cost a lot of money which
they weren't wrong so we took it to
universal who luckily wanted to do it
and wanted to do the r-rated version
you're in one room with with a bunch of
suits who don't see it in another room
with a bunch of suits who do luckily we
landed in in the right room it was a
pretty simple story in a lot of ways it
was it was something that you know came
out obviously my background in animation
but there was a movie called alien
nation with mandy patinkin that was
about
an alien invasion but it actually took
place five years after the aliens had
invaded so now they're like we all kind
of work together and that that was
oddly an influence
when it came to ted it's like okay well
we all know the magical fairytale story
of the thing that comes to life what's
the story that takes place you know 30
years later and the muppets were a big
influence what i always loved about the
muppets is that there wasn't there was
no gimmick there was never any the
animals can talk but only this you know
they can only talk to each other i think
the second muppet movie opened with
kermit fawzi are working at a newspaper
the world you've created is the world
where these things can talk and they're
part of our community it's not oh my god
that frog can talk it's that frog just
cut me off in traffic if you look at a
movie like ghostbusters it's like you
get one crazy out there thing and
everything else has to be really real
and their thing was okay there are
ghosts running around manhattan
everything else has to be grounded it's
new york city as we know it these guys
are basically bug exterminators who
happen to catch ghosts everything else
is about that world is real except for
this one thing like if the teddy bears
come to life everything else has to be
really grounded and normal like this is
not a fantasy world we're living in this
is boston it's two guys sitting on the
couch talking about absolutely
inconsequential stuff i mean but do you
think she might be expecting me to make
that kind of a move no no i don't think
she's and not only that it's the wrong
time it's a terrible idea i mean you got
the economy you got the the credit
bubble the supreme court i mean look at
haiti
yeah i guess i didn't think about that
yeah well that's you know it's a factor
i mean it's interesting we're doing a
ted series now for for peacock and
initially it's like all right this is a
22-minute series to do these moments
that have nothing to do with the story
but are just real asides that are so
much a part of what the movie was you
know it's we're having to kind of
rethink how we're doing this how we
structure it it's one of those things in
comedy that's that's strange is that
things that don't move the story forward
are not always things you want to pull
out it illustrates who these people are
and not what situation they're in at the
moment
dad
american that was a direct response to
the political climate at the time you
know it was immediate post 9 11. the
terrorists are everywhere and beyond
alert and you know that was stan's whole
character i don't know if i can stand
watch all night you've kept me up for
the past two days practicing singing
steve this is an opportunity to step up
and be a hero then you'll know what it
takes to really sing our national anthem
radio me if you have any problems i'll
do my best dad i want more than your
best steve for once i want you to do
fine roger was it was the damage that
comes with
having that job like i gotta house an
alien you guys thought i tried to kill
you hilarious
it's so therapeutic to laugh you know we
wouldn't have created that show if
family guy hadn't been canceled i didn't
set out to create two animated shows and
have them i'm very much somebody who
likes to work on one thing at a time see
it through to the finish and then start
on something else they were all in the
same building i was running back and
forth all day every day dealing with
these two shows and i i didn't really
feel like i was
really running either one and so i made
the choice to
delegate it to mike barker and matt
weitzman who i'd co-created it with and
go back and continue nurturing family
guy because we hadn't been back from
cancellation all that long in many ways
i'm i'm surprised when i talk to like
people in their 20s today they almost
know more about it than i do how to keep
it fresh is always the concern i mean i
i i'm not in the writers room i haven't
been in the writers room for about 10
years do you have a favorite character i
don't i don't really
have i mean at this stage you know brian
is the easiest character to voice stewie
certainly is is you know at the top of
that list whatever was in my head that
day was
you know is still paying for my house
but you know i look at a character like
roger and that character is kind of
mushroomed into something
very different probably not what i would
have done but people love it there's no
word to describe it
shmooplydong
that's not it but it's close you can
create a character but other writers
might be able to do something more
interesting with it and i think you see
that all over television brian and
stewie is a good example there's a
writer gary gennetti and the brian
stewie relationship which is now so
central to that show was something that
he really hit upon it can be good and
and bad to have a show go this long i
think family guy in a lot of ways has
consistent ups and downs i'm not going
to be the one to kill it at this point
a million ways to die in the west
i mean every western we've ever seen
centers around some paragon of nobility
and heroism and most of us aren't like
that most of us are not
are not uh you know in the gladiatorial
arena we're going like look at that
guy's haircut huh that's never who the
movie's about and that's who the
million ways to die in the west was
about it was it was it was about the
person who has a strong sense of
self-preservation as most of us do
what is there to live for on the
frontier in 1882 huh but let me tell you
something we live in a terrible place in
time the american west is a disgusting
awful dirty dangerous place look around
you everything out here that's not you
wants to kill you outlaws angry drunk
people scorned hookers hungry animals
diseases major and minor injuries
indians the weather you can get killed
just going to the bathroom i take my
life in my hands every time i walk out
to my outhouse the west is so glamorized
it's so romanticized
would have been terrible to live there
you know there's there's like probably
one restaurant you probably live miles
and miles and miles away from town you
got to ride a horse to get there even
when you do there's not that much to do
you can go into the saloon but it's full
of [ __ ]
you know where they're drinking in the
middle of the day probably no ice but
you go home and then you just wait for
it to get dark and read the bible like
what there's nothing to do but hollywood
has been telling us from years no it's
this glorious romantic epic you know era
in history again i was we were just
trying to take a spin on something
familiar that that hadn't really been
explored before when i did ted that was
my first foray into live action ever i
mean i'd come out of animation where you
plan everything every shot
you storyboard everything you can't do
coverage you can't have a wide shot and
a tight shot and over and i had in my
mind and sometimes on paper storyboarded
every scene
thinking all right we need this shot in
this shot and that's it moving on and my
producer really had to explain to me
that you should probably get some other
angles in case you want to mess with it
you know in post and i scoffed at it at
the times i i've done nothing but
animation i mean i was asking my
director of photography quietly you know
what's an over what's a 50 50 these
terms that as a director like hey you
should probably know it was a smart crew
and it was an experienced crew and they
knew that i was very green but they also
knew that i had a clear sense of what i
wanted this to be
and that i was ready to accept help as
far as the on-camera part of it ted
itself was not that much of a departure
from animation it was you know the
physicality was the same as that you do
in the booth when you're recording an
animated character
the western was was easily the most
challenging transition because it's a
little more dishonest voice over work
when you're on camera it's just there's
less of that it has to be it's so much
more nuanced in many many ways it was
about pulling back to this day it is
even with the orville it's about pulling
back it's about you don't have to give
as much that less is more
the orville
with the orville i really wanted to i've
been a fan of sci-fi for for since i was
a kid i love that genre of storytelling
the thing that you can do as a writer
where you're
commenting on something without actually
commenting on it you can take a a stance
the popular stance or an unpopular
stance and and tell it through the lens
of this alien culture and
and explore alternative viewpoints it's
a lot headier when you're working in
that genre and i i really
wanted to take advantage of that so the
orville began as something that was kind
of existing between two worlds i think i
found pretty early on that
i was much more attracted to one world
than the other
that i i didn't mind you know writing
the jokes but i really wanted to tell
the sci-fi stories about midway through
season two or maybe a little earlier
and certainly in season three which is
coming up in june
um we kind of cracked the nut of like
okay there is a humorous component to
this there is a loose
component but the humor is much more
character-based you know if you're
watching ally mcbeal
or you know if you're watching gilmore
girls the humor comes from who the
people are and not from the hard jokes
that you would get from a sitcom let me
see that shoulder
does it hurt yeah it hurts like hell
that means it's not that bad
what are you talking about kelly i
literally just said it hurts like hell
when he's really in pain he gets
straight answers with no cussing he's
just hoping to give him drugs that's a
bunch of crap kelly i'm in real pain
here i why do you have drugs similar to
albert i wanted ed to be somebody who
was a little bit more like somebody who
might be watching a show like this as
opposed to being in it you know i watch
it i watch a picard and i'm a fan but i
don't i can't relate to picard because
that's not what i would do in that
scenario i'd be like yeah call me when
it's over i i've written that character
in sync with how
my my own journey has felt to me this
ship
is what i've been waiting for my entire
career i've gotten more comfortable
being on camera i've gotten more
comfortable
directing more comfortable with the
world of live-action filmmaking and and
i've tried to kind of translate it that
into the characters the character
evolves
he becomes more comfortable in his job
he's a little bit more settled into his
chair it's a character that that is very
different as we as we go from season to
season
than he was early on which is kind of a
first it's it's you know with the
animated shows
people just stay the same they're frozen
in time with a movie you're there for an
hour and a half and you're gone
this is kind of the first time i've had
the opportunity to really develop
characters over the course of
of a long stretch of time and not just
ed
all the characters there are nine
regulars on that show it's definitely
where i felt the most relaxed and at
ease and the orville might be the most
fulfilling experience i've had since
i've been in hollywood